en gros il 13 est arrivé android reste
darriver pas sur tous les smartphones
android mais sur quelques-uns à
commencer par les pixels ici j'ai un
pixel six proches de l'utiliser pour
vous montrer j'ai fait une mise à jour
alors la mise à jour pourrait la faire
différentes manières soit vous venez
directement dans vos paramètres et vous
sélectionnez la mise à jour qu'on va
bien vous proposez c'est ce qui est
mieux si pour autant on ne vous propose
pas vous pouvez aller directement vous
cherchez android 13 peut venir le
télécharger directement vous allez lire
flash est bon c'est pas forcément un
truc le plus simple que je veux dire
vous recommander mais si vous voulez
réellement est tout de suite vous pouvez
venir le faire vous invite à venir faire
une petite recherche là dessus c'est
comme ça que j'ai fait en tout cas parce
qu'elle n'a pas été proposée alors
android 13 c'est la nouvelle version
d'android qui a été présenté au mois de
mai l'année dernière si je me souviens
bien d'ailleurs jeter chez google à ce
moment là mère si google de m'avoir
invité à cette occasion pour découvrir
les nouveautés chez vous avec un petit
verre à la menace t creuse plutôt pas
trop mal donc là on va venir regarder
dix nouveautés qui paraissent réellement
intéressante et d'ailleurs tiens puisque
je vous parle des nouveautés d'android
13 je vous ai présenté il ya quelques
jours le pixel s'ils savent j'en ai fait
mon tel donné mon retour donc je vous
invite à aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil à ma vidéo du pixel si ça et puis
on va se parler des six quelques jours
également des pixels bugs pro donc allé
jeter une oreille dessus un oeil dessus
si ces produits vous intéresse il est
100% google bien évidemment vous est
pris c'est parti
[Musique]
des nouveautés alors première nouveauté
qui est vachement intéressante c'est
souvenez-vous l'année dernière avec
android 12 google avait apporté matériel
uk était une vraie nouveauté en terme de
personnalisation et biens matériels ue
continuent à évoluer vous allez ici dans
vos paramètres vous venez juste en bas
ici dans fond d'écran est-il alors là
moi j'ai mis un petit fond d'écran un
peu coloré un peu péché l'histoire que
bien vous le voyez comme ça et bien en
fait qu'est-ce que la bière fait un
matériel you il va venir faire marcher
et courir votre fond d'écran en vous
proposant différentes combinaisons de
couleurs donc en fait vous n'avez
quelques-unes là vous monter jusqu'à 16
combinaisons de couleurs en partant de
ces teintes là donc ça c'est assez
rigolo regardez vous venez vous avez
tout ça donc vous choisissez en faites
ce que vous voulez toutes les
déclinaisons qui vont bien vous
intéresser pour votre thème pour vos
icônes alors il ya des trucs qui sont un
peu dégueu on va pas se mentir mais avec
ceux qui sont aussi vachement bien les
premiers me paraissent carrez met pas
trop trop mal on peut mettre un peu de
bleu également sur 20 peu de bleu allez
on va dire ça pourquoi pas donc ça c'est
les couleurs qui vont être à mélanger
qu'un petit patchwork et vous avez les
couleurs de base monochrome avec
également 16 couleurs donc en a un peu
plus on peut venir personnaliser
davantage ça c'est du matérial you
version android 13 autre évolution c'est
le lecteur média qui a évolué qui est
beaucoup plus sympa beaucoup plus clair
alors regardez je voulais me juste là
mon lecteur média est ici et là si vous
regardez de plus près et bien en fait il
est beaucoup plus intéressant je vois
mon morceau play pause j'ai accès aux
appareils qui sont connectés alors je
pourrais avoir mais pixels bugs promet
pour l'instant je les ai pas reliés à ce
téléphone l'a donc si j'ai un autre
appareil et bien je peux venir le
retrouver ici donc ça ce sont mes
appareils et puis j'aime la musique que
je vais venir retrouver là directement
donc c'est pratique c'est sympa
directement jeu ça plutôt pas mal fichu
je vais également sur mon écran
d'accueil ici voyez je viens de
retrouver avec les mêmes options voix ou
est ce que je veux venir diffusée sur ce
téléphone ou sur un appareil connecté
tout ça vraiment pas mal plutôt bien
fichu beaucoup plus joli surtout
beaucoup plus esthétique par rapport à
ce qu'on avait sur android 12 et puis
autre petit truc là regardez hop on va
venir pas ici vous avez votre petit
bouton qui est situé juste là pour venir
accédez à vos réglages très rapidement
en bas à droite le bouton pour venir là
lui bel et enfin surtout les femmes
parce qu'elle n'est pas bien là lui mais
puisqu'il déjà vu m bravo monsieur
groupe pour l'astuce pour soi voilà il
fallait le voir il fallait le savoir
autre chose et puisqu'on est sourd va
regarder ça là vous voyez et il est en
train de vous le marquer que vous avez
trois applications qui sont actives en
fait il voulait notifie ça c'est plutôt
pas mal et lorsque vous appuyez dessus
eh bien vous voyez les applications qui
sont actives alors là j'ai spotify qui
ne jouent de la musique je vais avoir
également mon interface android 13 qui
est juste là et puis j'ai samsung health
qui travaillent en font alors
l'interface d'android 13 je ne vais pas
l'éteindre par contre je peux venir
couper là si je le souhaite spotify par
exemple attaque j'arrête la musique est
bien décrit arrêtez donc c'est bien fini
ok samsung elle s'est également si je
veux arrêter je peux arrêter comme ça je
vois directement ici quelles sont les
applications voyez me reste plus qu'une
qui travaillent en tâche de fond je
trouve ça aussi assez malin assez
intuitif et puis surtout ça va vraiment
dans le sens de la sécurité apporte
toujours plus de sécurité toujours plus
d'informations alors puisqu'on parle
d'informations via une autre nouveauté
que je trouve aussi super bien c'est que
lorsqu'une application est bien se lance
pour la première fois elle va vous
demander une autorisation vous envoie
des notifications alors qu'avant elles
le faisaient directement on va se
prendre quoi par exemple un tick tock
allez hop tictoc autorisé tik tok à vous
envoyer des notifications aller
j'autorise donc ça c'est pour tik tok on
va se prendre quoi par exemple maintien
hub hérite de la même manière hop et il
me le demande directement autorisez-vous
hubert it's a besoin des notifications
j'autorise donc ça c'est plutôt cool et
je trouve que c'est bien une focus a
permis avant d'informer le consommateur
par rapport à ce qui se passe dans son
téléphone et ont fait le choix dès le
départ on est avertis autre nouveauté au
niveau des vibrations alors vous venez
dans vos paramètres ici et vous allez
dans son et vibreurs sont et vibreur et
vous allez dans vibreur et retour
haptique qui vient se trouvait juste ici
et là vous avez des petites choses en
plus des petits réglages un peu plus
fins notamment au niveau des vibrations
des notifications voyez vous venez les
peuples à choisir et sentir directement
la vibration sous le doigt vibreur d
alarme ok vous avez le retour haptique
donc ça aussi c'est très très bien
notamment pour une jeu bien évidemment
vibreur des contenus multimédias donc ça
c'est aussi une amélioration qu'on a
cette année sur android 13 qui est
plutôt mal alors c'est pas une très
grosse amélioration n'y a pas d'énorme
amélioration cette année là quelques
unes à droite à gauche qui ont quand
même plutôt sympa autre nouveauté qui
aussi pas mal c'est au niveau de la
traduction alors là vous venez dans vos
paramètres vous allez dans ce système
vous allez ensuite dans langue est
saisie juste là et là vous venez dans
l'angle des applis et là vous allez voir
les applications que vous pourrez
choisir dans différentes langues alors
direz vous quel est l'intérêt d'avoir
une application dans différentes langues
ça va avoir un sens en fait si par
exemple j'en sais rien vous êtes
bilingue avec une application vous
conviendra mieux en france et notre
mieux en anglais ou alors si vous voulez
vraiment une application dans une langue
particulière que ça peut être dans le
cadre d'études ça peut être pas mal de
choses là aujourd'hui j'ai que google
actualités qui me le propose et là je
peux choisir paramètres du système si je
me le met par exemple google actu en
english et bien je peux en jeu choisi je
m united states why not donc là lorsque
je vais vouloir ouvrir google actualités
que je vais venir chercher ici voilà
alors les notifications ça on l'a déjà
vu et pour le coup ici je suis en
anglais j'ai les infos de cnn j'ai le
washington post j'ai sky news j'ai nine
to five google donc là j'ai des infos en
fait qui me viennent de pays anglophones
et ça c'est plutôt pas mal donc si
effectivement envoyé typiquement ici je
veux pas du média français mais je du
média anglophone et surtout américains
et bien je vais bien me retrouver ici et
a contrario si je viens changé et que je
change ma langue ici google actualités
je vais mettre par exemple les
paramètres du système par défaut donc là
j'ai envie aux français je reviens ici
et là je me retrouve avec le figaro
france info la montagne que je suis
clermont ferrand 20 minutes ouest-france
voyez ça c'est vachement intéressant
c'est par exemple vous voulez lire aussi
des journaux j'en sais rien moi dans
n'importe quel pays du monde eh bien
vous avez ici directement accès en
changeant la langue directement dans vos
paramètres autre truc que je trouve
vraiment pas mal c'est les copier-coller
alors par exemple on va venir ici je
vais mettre sur wikipédia peu importe et
je vais venir faire un petit copier
alors hop là on vient sélectionné toute
une partie du texte dans l'eau jusque là
je fais copier et la voyez j'ai toute
cette petite partie en bas qui est pas
mal au niveau de moncaut piégé qu'à
cliquer ici et ça m'ouvre un petit
éditeur en fait qui me permet d'éditer
ce qui est copié donc tout ça vachement
intéressant alors le texte j'ai lu en
entier si par exemple moi je regardais
que le début et tout le reste je veux
venir le supprimer est-ce que j'ai copié
un peu trop et bien au plat je peux
venir
supprimer tout le reste la voilà je
sélectionne je vais jusqu'au la voie là
et je garde que ça et ça c'est quand
même vachement bien ensuite je fais ok
je viens retrouver toute ma partie là
qui est copié ici et là je peux venir la
partagez donc c'est beaucoup plus rester
c'est beaucoup plus visuel est beaucoup
mieux alors là je vous le montre
directement sur un texte mais je peux
faire exactement la même chose sur une
photo par exemple j'ai une petite photo
hop je vais ici je vais d'en copier
l'image je me retrouve avec pareil cette
petite partie qui est juste en bas et là
je peux venir directement à noter
griffonné en disant ben tiens par
exemple ça hop là jean tour ça je veux
le montrer une petite flèche rouge pour
vraiment signifier que c'est ça qui
m'intéresse je peux venir ajouter du
texte à coucou voilà qu'au coup par
exemple je suis à la fenêtre voyez donc
j'ai pas mal de possibilités et une fois
que j'ai fait ça et bien je fais
exactement la même chose c'est qu'au
pied avec mes petites annotations à mes
petites modifications que vous allez
voir directement la clique ici et je
peux venir le partager directement
l'envoyer par message renvoyait sur
instagram enfin bref c'est pas mal c'est
simple c'est intuitif et ça c'est cool
autre nouveauté pour le coup elle n'est
pas visuel à l'epa graphique vous avez
des nouveautés au niveau de l'audio il
s'en va pouvoir retrouver du spécial
audio de l'audio spatialisé et du
bluetooth et le low energy on en parlera
une prochaine fois et on également
compatible à midi 2.0 via l'usb autre
nouveauté alors si plus du petit point
de détail me direz vous c'est que vous
avez un lecteur de qr code qui est
intégré directement pas besoin
d'utiliser l'application google lance
pour venir à se caler un qr code vous
descendez ici directement et vous allez
la voir juste ici voilà attaque je viens
j'ai plus qu'à scanner le qr code comme
ça ça que qrcode maintenant on utilise
beaucoup des voix pas forcément pour des
trucs qu'on n'aurait pas envie notamment
pour les questions de covin mais c'est
comme ça ça nous a quand même vachement
aider donc la première scanner un qr
taux très très facilement directement
depuis ces petits raccourcis juste là
voilà pour ces quelques nouveautés ces
dix nouveautés que je trouvais
intéressante alors pris à tour des
petites bricoles google nous annonce
également une nouveauté en terme de
sécurité de paramètres de sécurité du
concours qui arrivera dans une version
ultérieure là je suis sur la version
d'android 0.0 enfin je crois que c'est
vraiment y'a même pas la version juste
android 13 c'est vraiment sur le tout
début donc à des choses qui arriveront
plus tard dans les mois à venir dont il
ya des nouveautés qui vont arriver comme
ça de temps en temps il est évident que
les nouveautés sont moins fortes sur
android presse que ce que vous aviez sur
android 12 mais c'est quand même
chouette de voir ces nouveautés je sais
pas laquelle vous botte le plus c'est ce
qu'un deuil qui vous botte parmi toutes
celles là est ce que le fait de pouvoir
venir customiser la porte un peu plus de
différentes couleurs ce que ça vous
intéresse oui non tous a marqué le mois
juste en bas en commentaire puis l'on
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler bien évidemment de google par
l'etec pareil plein de choses parce que
la bombe ont eu trop de cette vidéo je
vois tout ce qui arrive tout les tests
qui vont arriver toutes les nouveautés
et ça va être très dur prenez soin de
vous embrasser à très bientôt bisous
[Musique]